salut je suis Diane plus sage de la
haute direction ici à
Hawkstone ce beau lac que nous avons
ici c'est un rocher naturel nous sommes à l'est
nous nous moquons de votre richesse nous voulons que
tous ceux qui sont coupables connaissent
la terreur de leur crime c'est  facile quand
ce n'est pas ta vie facile quand ce n'est
pas chez toi mais quand c'est de ta faute ça
ne devrait pas être si facile de dormir la nuit
surtout quand on sait où tu habites
pourquoi tu nous espionnes ou
t'espionne nous empoisonne nous empoisonnons
nous  va contre-attaquer trois
sociétés dans les six prochains mois pour
le terrorisme mondial et ce n'est que
le début